these next nominees used animation to
make the most of their limited screen
time employing a variety of visual
Styles and techniques to carry out a
story in 40 minutes or less in just 24
minutes one nominee even managed to fit
in an entire Year's worth of
what what what Pedro well you'll you'll
find out when you watch this oh how
thrilling
here are the nominees for best animated
short film
the boy the mold The Fox and the horse
Charlie McAfee and Matthew Freud
the flying sailor Amanda forbus and
Wendy Toby
ice Merchants joao Gonzalez
my year of dicks Sarah gunas daughter
and Pamela ribbon
and ostrich told me the world is fake
and I think I believe it Lachlan
Pendragon
[Applause]
the boy the mole The Fox and the horse
Charlie McAfee and Matthew Freud
[Music]
the animation team behind the boy the
mold The Fox and the horse work remotely
throughout covet to create a look that
closely resembled the ink and watercolor
illustrations from the book on which it
was based
we've never made a film before so this
is bewildering uh Beyond and I know the
protocol is to say thank you a lot but
I'm British
so I'm more comfortable saying sorry
um so I'm really sorry to all the people
who should be on the stage with us with
an extraordinary team with Cara speller
and Peter bainton and JJ and Hannah and
Izzo and John and our amazing cast and
over 100 animators
um I'm also really sorry to my children
and my girlfriend and my colleagues at
Freud's for basically being absent for
the last two years as this film took
flight but this statue is for the dog
Vincent and the boy Charlie
um hello oh I'm sorry I'll be brief it's
a recurring theme the apology
um I just I was in my Village very
recently and a lady came up to me and
said you're going to that Oscar thing
and I said yeah and I said I think I'll
need help and remember my clothes and
she said you will and and and it's a
recurring theme with clothing and myself
and she then said it's a long pause and
she said you know Charlie I think it
takes a lot of courage to make a film
and I think when you go there there'll
be a lot of very very brave people in
the same room
and I looked I said yay I think you're
right and it's really true and uh the
the people that I've worked with they've
tolerated me for two years and they're
Brave and kind and thank you so much and
thank you to my mum and my family and my
dog who I've left behind who's who's in
actually in a hotel I hate to say that I
can't search
um
I wasn't really meant to say that I'm
sorry anyway thank you so so much for
this and thank you
foreign
[Music]